so infographics are way to present data
in a visual way and by doing so
hopefully to give us a better
understanding of the data what I've got
to show you today is what's been called
the greatest infographic of all time
here it is it was devised by man called
Charles Minard he was a French civil
engineer he used to make infographics in
his retirement and this describes
Napoleon's disastrous invasion of Russia
in 1812 through this infographic you see
at the beginning of 1812 Napoleon's
Empire was at its height he had or an
army of size 422 thousand men now you
can see the size of his army by the
width of this line so here they are
they're in cono it's in Lithuania
they're here and they decide to attack
Russia so they're going through
Lithuania they're going through Belarus
and they're going moving onwards to
Russia they're trying to encounter the
Russian army but the Russian army they
keep falling back that pushes the French
army forwards they keep being dragged
for us then the Russian army fall back
and they've been dragged forwards again
as the Russian army fall back they are
burning villages down they are burning
the crops to prevent the French army
from living off the land so in that case
the French have to live up the supplies
they brought with them to supply this
large army it wasn't possible
there were starvation people were
drinking out of puddles they were eating
rotten food people were going off camp
at night trying to find food if they did
the Russians would find them they would
kill them so we can see how many men
they're losing by the way this brown
line is getting thinner and thinner and
thinner they're moving into Russia
they're going up to here they finally
catch up with the Russian army just
outside of Moscow
so now at this point they have only 127
thousand men left this is the location
of a great battle a very bloody battle
so at this ad this battle they lost
27,000 men here they started with 127
thousand and then here as they move on
forward you can see we now have 100,000
men so we got this step here that shows
you that sudden decrease the Russian
army they retreat they disappear and so
the Polian now can ride into Moscow
victorious so he rides into Moscow with
his a hundred thousand men however the
Russians deny him his victory they
refuse to concede they evacuate the town
the people who are left in Moscow are
given orders to burn the place to the
ground so here they are in Moscow and
they are forced to go back still got no
supplies they're still in their summer
gear it's now winter down here it tells
you the temperature of that winter it's
a very cold winter it goes down to minus
21 degrees C and this is the black line
showing and going back the way they came
you can see the number of men who are
dying when it gets thinner and thinner
these points this is Charles Menard
using the data that he got from
historical documents he was representing
that data these drops in numbers using
his black line here getting thinner and
thinner there are more men who died
through starvation and disease desertion
and then they died in all the battles
combined now by the time they get to
this river they had a disastrous
crossing they started with 50,000 men by
the time they crossed this river they
only had what is that 28,000 men this
not only does this tell us the
temperature of that winter not only does
it tell us how many men they were losing
as they marched across it also shows as
other things it shows just off shoots as
troops of men have off shoots they go
off somewhere else and then they rejoin
so we
can see here 60,000 men on the way to
Moscow 60,000 men break off they stay
round here they have their own problems
here yes 33,000 men come back and join
the retreating French army here they
rejoined so now you can see that this
line does increase in size Edward Tufte
who's an expert in these infographics he
described this infographic as 6
variables plotted including the size of
the army its location on a
two-dimensional surface the direction of
the Army's movement the temperature at
various states during the retreat from
Moscow and it perhaps the best the
typical graphic ever drawn
we're marching through Lithuania Belarus
without marching into Russia we are
encountering Russian armies we're having
a battle over here sudden drop in the
number of men we you finally walk into
Moscow only to be disappointed we are we
have to return
we have no supplies we have to return
where you turn back with this black line
as we return death famine disease
follows us as we returned out the men as
decreasing and decreasing we are not
prepared we don't have what we need
we do have a rejoin here of some men
farmer who have been waiting for us but
even then we try and cross this river
disaster again sudden drop in men back
the way we came all the way to where we
started in Lithuania at the end we have
10,000 men where we started with four
hundred and twenty-two thousand men